okay hi I'm David Kass and I've never
done this before talking to the computer
that's going to be presented but I want
to thank you for viewing my presentation
I would like to start with a funny joke
but I don't know any so I'm gonna get
right into my presentation so let's go
here on my first slide so you can see
that the title of my talk wants to
generate authentic research experiences
and forensic based projects and
undergraduate laboratory which extends
beyond just forensics but being this
forensic conference I'm focusing on that
aspect okay also note that we are
predominantly an undergraduate Institute
and education part comes first and
that's why this is more an educational
research project than straight forward
classic research experiment okay so okay
so there's two projects and all are
designed to be consortium based so the
project's focus on genomics and genomics
lends itself to being consortium based
and the data can consistently be added
as we develop databases to do these
analyses okay project one I'll talk
about the two projects the project one's
development and used to have been an
ally of value-based Tetra plexus for
forensic ancestry and population
genetics and then project two will be
the use of mammalian l1 sequences for
generating a tree allowing also for
forensic determination of unknown
samples I still start project one
developing and using these Allen based
exercises that I've been working on
designing as background for educational
settings the most commonly markers that
are used where students take
a swab of their DNA and then we PCR and
and run an agarose gel is the d1 SAT
vntr and the p90 - island dimorphism
those are the two main markers in use
hey they're simple to use d1 SAT is the
vntr got 16 based repeats there is 29 a
wheel so it's informative which 435
possible combinations the primary
drawback is that you have to run it on
acrylamide gel and agarose gels which
students are more comfortable with you
can never get resolution to really
determine the alleles and pv 92 is an
example of a sign which are short
interspersed DNA elements they're small
75 to 500 base pairs and the alyou
element is the primary sign in primate
genomes with over a million copies
though them and these are
retrotransposons and a hubba slide in
the second where these amplify
throughout the genome and that's where
you got your million copies by process
of a retro transposition which requires
an RNA in the media these are RNA
polymerase 3 transcribe and they're a
ton non-autonomous they require some
other machinery no coding proteins and
so here's a generic sign I'll show you
it has um I keep clicking the slide and
spin the next thing okay so here we go
so next we've got the internal RNA
polymerase 3 promoter boxes we've got an
a tail which is shown to being critical
for the ability to read for transpose
and most copies are not competent
through our retro transpose is only a
few so-called master genes and you've
got flanking directory gates which are
found
13 basis ranges but there at the ends
there the product of the actual
integration event because there's stager
NYX when they integrate into the genome
so here's kind of just a representation
you have a master gene and you got your
enlarged view of it so you can see TV
it's copied to RNA and reversed
transcribed into cDNA and that cut and
so on the bottom you have another
chromosome that happens you nicked and
then the copy the cDNA is integrated
into a new chromosomal site so the
second strand of DNA is generated and
you've got a copy so there's only a few
master genes and over a million copies
okay so um
allo Elam and here's an example of
generating what's called in a Lou
dimorphism yellow dye morphism is where
you simply have presence or absence of
an element so it's a polymorphism but
there's only two forms presence or
absence and as you can see on the slide
in a Lou from the master gene so there's
the copy you can integrate it into a
certain chromosomal site and then you
have your derived form that contains an
Al you and your ancestral form without
the ally and when so lots of individuals
including myself have looked for the
younger alga elements the ones that
aren't in grading more recently and are
not fixed in the Union genome out of the
million you know copies that are out
there so an estimated about two thousand
five thousand dimorphic a little in the
genome and so what's nice about this
it's easy to use and as you can see if
the AL u is present you've got a forward
or any first primer which are the same
for both cases there and you get three
genotypes individual kid both
chromosomes have the ally can be
heterozygous or it can be homozygous for
not having the ally when it's easily
identified on the two
I arose gel hey this is PV 92 as I
mentioned the common the news money you
can see you get clear results very
simple to use simple PCR reaction crude
preps of DNA from cheek swabs and run on
an agarose gel and we used gel red as a
stain because it's not toxic like gum
the cancerous like a fitting girl right
is okay but what I've done is taken a
step further and rather than use single
individual alloy elements is to generate
what I refer to as a lead tetra plexus
because you're looking at for a lose
simultaneously missing the reaction and
so number one okay that's an ally at a
certain location choose a different
locus okay so we've got these four
different loci here
any idea is to design primers that are
spaced out where you need to be able to
identify the variants on electrophoresis
on agarose gel okay so we click here you
can see plus salad - salad for number
one I'll show the arrows there and then
maybe for number two you can identify
them there and there's three and there's
four and so the idea is that you can
distinguish before plus and minus
valentine morphisms on the single gel
okay so how how do I do this first you
want to identify what's referred to as
intermediate frequency alleys and pain
that from the literature the ideas you
want both that or comment if one is rare
it's not going to be overly informative
and then amplify individual most I'm
just getting to work identify
heterozygotes or you can take the
homozygote and a heterozygote and mix
them together and then try doing two at
a time
and for me I tried all kinds of
combinations and what I found is using
failsafe
by epicenter which is now part of
Lumina works best with buffer your eye
and we have a whole series of buffers
okay so then find pairs that work well
together fine-tune them hey if you've
got a trip flexed already then we go to
step 7 to get the Tetra flex if she's
got a duplex then go to the back to step
forward and get the triplets and then
fine-tune usually primer concentrations
are key thing for one thing band
intensities can chain be different if
it's heterozygous versus homozygous and
also the higher molecular weight bands
usually are less intense than then low
molecular weight bands so please you
have to consider when developing these
different prices okay
oh sorry and and uni and it's a good
idea to verify that means tetra plexus
match up when you're just doing
individual primer sets okay so here's an
example of the album tetra Paks
profiling system getting crude craft
stores for several years and so here is
an example individual number five is
heterozygous first locus 51 i
heterozygous for locus 182 heterozygous
for the ace locus and homozygous for
lacking the aliens for the TPA locus
okay so i've presented the genotype for
that individual individual number six is
actually heterozygous for every single
warning has eight bands there and so if
we want to try a paternity analysis in
this technique individual number six
again is heterozygous so uninformative
because you can't tell if you know got
that band from the mother and the father
so here's the second touch plex i
develop and
again number six as the mother in this
case number six is homozygous for the
four different loci and the idea is to
make sure that the children all the
bands and the children can be accounted
for them by the mother or the father if
they can't then you can exclude the
father okay so six is the mother five is
a father a potential father and seven
and eight are the children on the other
represents a mother family okay so seven
and eight the two children have ninety
two rather nine plus and so the father
has nine plus okay so it's consistent
okay a child number labeled number seven
and got a band that's not present in the
mother okay which is sixty - but got
that bad from the father and as we
continue number 225 which is an unusual
situation I don't have time to talk
about that we'd gladly discuss I have a
paper on that one and so child number
eight got that from the father and over
here all children have the 15 - allele
and dad contributed fat so father number
five cannot be excluded so it's a lot
easy to exclude someone then you know
prove it but in this case that's all
consistent they also developed a third
touch of Plex and by doing that I've
gone from 81 possible genotypes to
65,000 and when you include a third one
so twelve flows site we've got over 500
31,000 possible profiles so again
thinking in terms of undergraduate
classroom it's a simple to use method
and you can generate very complex
phenotypes and we compared to CODIS you
got the 13 short tandem repeats and you
can see the probability of a match
10 to the minus 15 what's interesting
about all new elements is that they're
almost free markers so if you have a GU
kid universe there's a see at a certain
location could be a reverse mutation but
these are Homo plays you freeze the
leaves have to be identical by descent
because the odds of two integrating for
the same spot or astronomical and they
don't exercise precisely like they
integrated there are couple of systems
where you can analyze 30 markers at once
and get close to the discriminatory
power of CODIS one would be to analyze
each one of them individually which is
quite laborious and the expensive and
there's a system out there that's pretty
cool
based on flanking direct repeats but
requires the capillary system
fluorescent dyes and so it's not the
best tool for undergraduate classroom
although it's a really good tool okay so
the purpose of doing that what I propose
here or what I've kind of started is
with the ally tetra flex system fewer
reactions and do fewer many girls so
it's rapid low cost and if I could I'm
working on a fourth text reflects that
and you can see you have 43 million
possible profiles with that I still has
a class forensic experiment students
would select a number from calling ahead
but a beaker or anything they rolled up
paper so it's anonymous and they only
know what their number is unless they
tell somebody else students each
students here in a swab and an
extraction solution and they label the
tube with the number from there that
they've added a hat okay and they
followed protocol which lasts maybe like
15 to 30 minutes it's not very long
protocol to do it's a crude crap and I
can put you can put students into three
groups each developing or Metroplex
master mix they're Alec rotting into
number tubes which they do and then the
student let's say student number one
we'll add there so here's Alec line
shown in this figure and student number
one would put his her or her DNA into
two number one for the three potential
exes and in the original number two and
so on and then as the instructor I would
choose one of these samples and place
that as the unknown and then we have
negative control with no DNA okay so
here's the class forensic analysis as
you can seeing you get quite a lot of a
lot of variation in the profile and then
okay well which is the unknown and so
can you die identify the unknown and
it's clearly number 11 number four
number four number four is an exact
match for the unknown and it should be
because I picked number four as the
unknown which the students didn't know
what number I picked so this works as a
nice class forensic analysis we could do
population analyses there is a lot of
data for these regarding population in
the real frequencies and so here's an
example here and we can I look at
genetic distances between populations
and here's from a paper where you've got
Egyptian versus african-american
populations for these various markers
and if you have 0.25 or higher you have
pretty high genetic variation between
the populations and there are three that
are very high particularly with a ly9
marker okay and all of this has been
part of the thousand genomes project and
Watkins paper there's a number a large
number of populations they looked at for
a lot of these valley markers so we
already know their frequencies from a
good number of populations say regarding
ancestry because the ancestry students
just send their samples out and get some
information and there's no idea how that
information was obtained
this kind of shows a little bit greater
understanding but so if we assume the
world population is in hardy-weinberg
equilibrium and a student had
particularly genotype one that I showed
you here
um the chance of that genotype would be
one out of a million right but when you
compare different ethnic origins if
African American ancestry you would
expect based on allele frequencies one
point one seven times ten to the minus
seven probability Egyptian in order of
magnitude difference thankful that
profile that is an order of magnitude
more likely Egyptian than African
American ancestry so it just gives you
some idea and I mean it's not totally
foolproof accurate it's some idea and
along these lines I've developed a
website I mean if anyone's interested
the my outline here what the website is
and it models the Cold Spring Harbor
website for the p90 to accept this
includes at this point right now it
includes eight of the alleys and you can
compare the aloo elements frequencies
hardy-weinberg equilibrium you could
compare make a class of population
compared to another class or I
incorporated data from different
populations and can compare class
population to an actual population so
we're gonna continue developing this
some more as there's a project
continuous okay okay so that was kind of
it for project number one project number
two I'm using l1 sequences which is a
member of the long interspersed DNA
normal developments l1 is found in
mammals they're found in all mammals
and the idea here is to bias
amplification of Elaan young Elwin
elements and develop a tree of life and
see if we can use it as a forensic
determination of unknown samples okay so
the l1 as an internal promoter but in
this case RNA polymerase 2 and you have
your five Prime and three prime
untranslated regions as you would for
other protein coding sequences you have
an open reading frame it's actually
called that or flan which was the RNA
binding protein and it's apparently sis
acting still recognize its own RNA and
allow for the retro transition retro
transposition process and morph 2 is the
protein that's involved with being an
endonuclease and reverse transcriptase
ok there's also an a tail and again that
seems to be important for the retro
transposition process and again the
hallmarks of any trans poseable element
is that when it integrates that yields
flanking the references okay so how do
we determine young elements well we kind
of look at lots of element elements and
develop a consensus sequence and then we
utilized what's purchased concerted
evolution so in other words when you're
looking at lots of elements they'll
share certain sequences so in this
particular case and you have an
ancestral l1 from an ancestral species
and it made copies these copies
accumulate random mutations so that's
what the XS are they're all random
mutations okay and through time the
master gene so that what's shown is
ancestral l1 is the master doing that
generates copies okay you have might
have a variant with in that master gene
and all the copies then so species 2 has
a diagnostic nucleotide
and and all the copies will have the N
in them and then the same for species
one has a different end I put it at a
different position and and it'll still
acquire random mutations but the ones
that are more similar to a consensus
sequence which represents the master
gene would be your younger elements and
so we've got species one would have an
end at a certain position diagnostic
nucleotide and species team and it's
diagnostic before the time okay so we
want to bias for younger elements in the
or for two regions the most conserved
region so develop primers based on the
most conservative agents and I'm just
I'd have to use several slides to show
you the whole l1 but or even or two so
it's just a portion of the orc to
sequence among different species
mammalian species
okay so develop try different primer
sets from that and then as students we
had 12 DNA samples and again got him in
groups and in the PCR and so the first
gel shows one primer stack with 12 DNA
samples and the negative control and
then the second ones of different
primers that are learning is the third
primer set all of them were able to
amplify products at the right at the
expected molecular weight egg except the
last one there were a couple on the
bottom there we only see two and maybe a
third one so we chose primer step number
one to continue with this thing okay and
so continuing what we did was shotgun
cloned them into a TA cloning vector and
essentially generated these intra l1 PCR
libraries because each band that you see
is not a single locus represents
thousands of different l1 elements found
throughout the genome
okay so we generated these libraries
and we used blue white colonies election
and then plasmid preps and and analyzed
them on a gel and verify the size of the
inserts and then had them sequenced and
so this is one example of of a sample
where we had five different clones and
develop a consensus sequence and you can
see there's very high similarity that 99
percent and 6 percent 97% to each other
and to the consensus sequence so kind of
verifies that we did biased for younger
elements using these or two based
primers okay now what do we do with this
regarding a Tree of Life in forensics
I'm gonna start with the forensics ok so
the students what they did was to if
they're sequences and then each one of
them they called him a gave him
different clone name so all clone number
ones more than one a to 1b were from the
same DNA sample and then two and was
from the same sample and so on so number
one they got several clones and when
they did a GenBank screen it showed the
Norway rat Rattus norvegicus and then we
tell them okay well your sample was the
back number two it looks like it would
be the rabbit and you know it was rabbit
number three looks like the dog however
it was the Fox and then you might say
well that didn't work out well but
there's a lack of hoc sequences in
GenBank of Elwin elements so it makes
sense that we find the closest relative
same same is true for the Aztek mouse
which is peromyscus Aztecas not in the
database but we've got two maniculatus
and other peromyscus species so it
corresponding to that sample number 10
was the dog and then it matched up to
dog sequences and then we had that
chimpanzee although in this case you've
got you
as well as chimpanzee but chimpanzee did
come out on top and so forensic ly
they're able to use this and identify
the source of the DNA sample that they
not and then secondly developing a
mammalian tree of life and and it's
pretty consistent with what is known
well and in fact what's nice is all the
rabbit sequences you can see the blue
circle they're clustered together the
house mouse sequences clustered and with
not lots of variation little more
variation in the debut in the fox but as
we keep developing primers as we add
more mammals then lineage should we
expect it to come out more precise in
fact both the carnivores and in the
primates or both even though it might
look like the carnivores are more
related and when you look at the numbers
on this they're equally distant from the
others but but the house mouse and the
and the rat are related they they form a
clade the Daegu and guinea pig are
somewhat related and they form a clade
dog and Fox you can see the dog there is
right in the middle of all these Fox
sequences and the rabbit it comes out
just outside the rodents so it's pretty
much working out nicely again there's
lots of work to do but so far so good
thanks so but we want to do is generate
a database of student intra l1 sequences
something we're working on having grant
under review hope to continue with that
okay so to summarize and I'm looking at
my on-air time doing pretty good close
to 30 minutes the other types of flight
system we develop a rapid simple rapid
cost conscious accessible tool and
dnase and work is here but DNA profiling
for the undergrad laboratory and with
several different applications that you
can use it for and what's nice is we
continue to develop database it
especially for forensic part students
just incorporate it and eventually we
find out when the frequencies of the
entire population of individuals that
have contributed the profiles
anonymously of course okay for the intra
l1 DNA PCR libraries I've shown that we
had biased it for the younger elements
it's the useful learning experience with
a whole set of molecular tools and
there's a forensic component as well as
overall generating an amount real-life
component so anyway thanks for listening
to my presentation feel free to follow
up with any questions via email and
again thanks for listening